today we go back to my favorite place on
the internet tick tock and i say that uh
both ironically
and also sort of not ironically it's
kind of confusing and
i have a feeling we're about to be a lot
more confused because today we will be
watching and reviewing
some crazy dog owner videos on tick tock
there are a lot of these
there apparently no surprise and i'm a
well-known
dog loather not lover but loather
nothing against dogs personally i just i
find them irritating
and useless and disgusting what are you
doing
that's how i roll i don't blame them for
that there's something personal against
they're animals
they can't help affect their hairy mangy
useless beasts
i blame instead the dog owners and also
america's obsession
with dogs which has become i think a
sort of mental illness
in this country no offense to any dog
owners out there
so we'll we'll go through and we'll see
how bad these gets uh
these get let's let's start here things
tick tock made me buy part five
we've been seeing these tiny little
glasses all over tick tock so i knew i
had to get ducky a pair
these frames are from the paw wag
company and they're 12.99 i got him two
frames one in a size small and one in a
size medium to see which ones would fit
him better
these ones are the size small it's the
round glasses in black
i think they're so stinking cute on him
it also comes with a connector that
helps the glasses stay on his face
i personally like to size small frames
better on him but we're going to try on
the medium ones next
these ones are the round glasses in gold
in a size medium
these are definitely still cute
especially if you're going for a more
hipster oversized look
these are ducky approved and we give
these a 10 out of 10 and we can't wait
to get more
[Music]
dog glass does the dog need glasses did
you take him to lenscrafters and he got
a
an eye exam and no probably not because
he has no vision problem
at all i assume right he's not visually
disabled
you're basic you're forcing him to live
like that you're forcing a a trans-abled
identity on this poor dog
because you think glasses are cute
as a visually impaired american myself
you see these these glasses this is not
for show i need these
i have special eyes i just want to say
my culture
is not a damned costume for a dog you
bigot also now that poor dog has to run
around with this thing attached to his
face
which serves no medical purpose at all
and come to think of it we could
probably all relate
let's uh let's keep going uh
[Music]
that what was that the dog
was that the noise coming from a dog
this is sickening to me
you know there's a book that came out
recently it's a good book called the
decadent society and uh i think that
these videos
are all the proof you need that we live
in a decade a tie
what what is he what is he going for a
job interview with petsmart welcome to
costco
i love you what's the dog need a tie for
and just because he's putting his paw
on something that doesn't mean that he's
choosing to wear it okay
[Music]
the dog is a dog he's not he's just
randomly putting his
his paw this is something we always do
we we ascribe human intentions
to to to animals it's one of the reasons
why people always say oh look at the
dolphin
in the ocean jumping around he's so
happy
look he's smiling no his mouth is just
like that he can't help it
or you see a video of like a lion
cuddling a
tortoise and everyone says isn't it so
nice they're friends
no as soon as the video cut off he
ripped that tortoise's head off
your dog is fine he all your dog he's a
dog he wants to run around and the fur
god gave him
that's what your dog wants wants to do
you hear me you wacko pet owners that's
all he wants
the animals just want to they want to be
animals and they want to live like
animals because they're animals
he doesn't want to be your baby doll i
don't even like animals and i'm the one
sticking up for their rights here
these these people are going to turn me
into a pita activist
before too long i think it gets even
worse let's let's keep watching
that that to me is creepy that freaks me
i actually find i'm not even kidding i
find this deeply
on a real visceral level i find that
very disturbing that whole scene
because you see the look in the dog's
face i know i just said we can't
describe human
emotions and intentions to animals but
there i think
there are times you can just tell and
the look on the dog's face was was a
look of saying help me he's pleading
with the camera
to the pleading with the public come and
rescue me from this
serial killer i'm living with
because you know the dog did shoot dogs
don't lie down like that
that's not how a dog went she forced
that dog to lay there you know how many
takes it probably took
she's cause she's got her belt out
whipping the dog get in the bed
and be cute damn it that's what happened
you don't see that part on camera
listen man if you're dating a woman and
she has a little dog like
in fact if she has a little dog at all
that's a good reason to run away but
especially if she has a literal bed
with a nightstand and a lamp that by the
way the dog can't turn that lamp on and
off
then that's a that's a good indication
that this woman will murder you
in your sleep there's actually
statistically it's there's been
studies on this statistically 95
of owners of small dogs have at least
one human body
in a freezer in the basement i don't
know if you knew that but that's that's
pure science right there that's not
me talking that's science let's keep
[Music]
going
[Music]
so the dog has a tv and a fireplace you
know the vast majority of
and this is true this is like true the
vast majority of of the world's
population
does not live as well as that dog and i
don't mean that as a compliment to the
owner
this is a larger systemic problem
did you know americans and this this
also is true
americans spend close to a hundred
billion dollars a year
on their pets true
figure 100 billion we could solve
world hunger in a month
if you maniacs would stop taking your
dog to the spa
that's all it would take you know that i
won't stop
until i make you mine you know that i
won't stop
now's probably a good time to mention if
you haven't if i haven't already
emphasized this that your dog is a dog
he's not your child he's not your baby
there's nothing worse than people when
they talk about their they treat their
dog like a child
and it's even worse when it's a person
who actually has kids
and you hear this all the time someone
will say oh uh you know we have three
kids
and then you find out that no they have
two kids and a labradoodle
what you're saying is that you view your
child as a
you view your children as dogs it's not
so much
elevating the dog to the status of human
you are you are
degrading you are demoting the humans in
your families to the status of dogs
um okay we got a couple others that will
play for some reason let's do that
here's one of a dog bathing this will be
fun
[Music]
uh
what why we rose petals in a bath
for a dog i've never understood the rose
petals in the bath thing at all
i don't understand baths at all like why
would i want to sit in a stew
of my own grime and filth for 45 minutes
i don't see the point of that but
if you're gonna do it you know for for a
dog
a dog you just take the dog outside with
a hose hey that's it
use some dawn dish soap squirt the thing
down spray him with the hose
done you're done in two minutes rose
petals gives us a very uncomfortable
sort of intimate sort of vibe
and it makes me concerned that things
are happening in that home
that are illegal in 37 states except
texas
um all right let's let's continue
what you put that much effort into a
meal for your dog and money that
that lunch probably cost 115 dollars
and meanwhile your dog would eat literal
[ __ ] okay that's what your dog would
like to eat
how long does it take if that if it
takes that long to make your dog's lunch
how long does it take you to make yours
six hours by the time you're ready eat
lunch it's already dinner time or
maybe i'm i'm i could be i'm getting
this wrong because it's it's
i wouldn't put it past these
self-flagellating obsessive dog owners
uh to just you know they give the dog
that meal and then they eat dog food
themselves because these are the same
people who always go on about oh we
don't deserve dogs
we don't deserve them this is why dogs
are overrated it's not about it's not
about dogs themselves dogs are overrated
because we
just because we rate them so high we
rate them like literal angels
this is why if you're gonna own a pet
stick with something simple low
maintenance
like uh i don't know a sea sponge or an
amoeba
i had a pet amoeba when i was a kid i
couldn't see it but i knew it was there
that was a good pet or just don't own
pets at all that's also good
and live your life with dignity as a
human at the top of the food chain
where you belong not debasing yourself
in service to some lowly beast